en este vídeo quiero familiarizarte con
la idea del límite
esta es una super idea que es la base de
todo el cálculo y a pesar de ser una
idea tan importante en realidad es una
idea muy simple pero mucho muy simple
así que déjame definir una función y
definamos algo simple así como que fx es
igual a x 1 dividido entre x menos uno
un seguro vas a decir si tengo lo mismo
en el numerador y en el denominador algo
que está dividiéndose por sí mismo eso
sólo sería igual a 1 que no podríamos
simplificarlo simplemente a fx igual a 1
pero la diferencia de fx igual a 1 a
esto que tenemos aquí es que esta
expresión no está definida cuando
equivale a 1
y si ponemos a ver voy a escribirlo por
aquí
efe de de ser uno no no digo es f1 esto
va a ser en el numerador 11 que es pues
un 0 y en el denominador será uno menos
1 que también es 0 así que cualquier
cosa dividida por 0 incluyendo al 0 pues
no está definido no está definido
puedes hacer la simplificación o sea
puede simplificar y decir que esto es
exactamente igual que escribir de fx es
igual a 1 pero tienes que agregar una
restricción en la cual debes de indicar
que x no puede tomar el valor 1 y así
esta expresión y está de este lado son
equivalentes esta y ésta van a tomar el
valor de 1 para todos los valores de x
que no sea el 1 así que como gráfico
esta función una vez vamos a dibujar por
aquí este es mi eje
efe de x
este que está acá es pues mi eje x y
aquí voy a tener el valor de 1
x es igual a 1 de este lado esta x es
igual a menos 1 ahora estará igual a 1
más abajo está el -1 pvc eso es tan
importante así que
para cualquier x distinto de 1 f x vale
1 o sea que se verá una línea como ésta
continúa excepto en el punto que vale 1
aquí tengo un hueco así que lo voy a
dibujar con este pequeño círculo para
indicar que tengo un hueco en ese punto
donde x vale 1 y luego continua
la definición no nos dice qué vamos a
hacer en ese punto es indefinida
así que esta es la función la que
tenemos aquí y si alguien nos preguntara
cuánto vale
efe de uno pues esta es una definición
de una función y hay un hueco aquí
déjenme volverlo a escribir aunque sea
un poco redundante
efe de uno no está definido pero qué
pasa si les pregunto hacia dónde se está
acercando esta función
es decir a medida que x se va acercando
más y cada vez más a uno así que cuando
nos vamos acercando cada vez más y más y
más a uno a donde se acerca la función
por el lado izquierdo no importa que
tanto me acerca a uno mientras no llegue
a el fx sigue valiendo uno y por el lado
derecho tenemos una situación muy muy
similar así que podríamos decir y cada
vez estarás más familiarizados con estas
ideas porque además harás muchos más
ejemplos que el límite esto es l&m
cuando x se va acercando a 1 cuando se
va acercando a uno de fx es igual a a
medida que te acercas y te acercas
increíblemente infinitamente te acercas
y nuestra función será igual a 1
mientras x se acerca a 1 sin llegar a 1
durante todo el tiempo así diremos que
él
cuando x se va acercando a uno de fx es
igual a 1
y bueno tenemos una anotación un poco
caprichosa pero estamos reflexionando
sobre qué pasa cuando x se acerca a 1 y
qué pasa con fx es momento de hacer otro
ejemplo para que tengas bien la idea
general hagamos otro ejemplo y
analicemos su gráfica solo digamos que
tenemos
efe de x aunque mejor lo cambiamos a g x
para que haya un poco de variedad
y estar definida como
como x al cuadrado cuando
x sea distinto de 2
y para cuando x sea igual a 2 estará
definida como 1 así que otra vez tenemos
un caso interesante en esta función como
puedes ver no es continua presenta una
discontinuidad y ahora voy a graficar la
este es mi eje de la fd x este es mi eje
x ahora voy a dibujar este cuando x vale
2 así que tengo el 1 tengo el 2
por este lado está el menos 1 aquí está
el menos 2 y ahora voy a dibujar y en
todos lados excepto en donde x vale dos
tenemos x cuadrado que es una parábola
así que vamos a dibujar la más o menos
como
no creo que mejor este vamos a hacer
otro intento y si esta parábola se ve
más o menos así y la verdad no es la
parábola más bella en la historia del
dibujo de parábolas y nos tiene que dar
la idea de que hay una simetría pero
mejor a de otro intento entonces en este
intento a ver aquí vamos ya que eso aquí
vamos y muy bien esto se ve muy bien
entonces esta es la gráfica de x al
cuadrado pero no es x al cuadrado cuando
x vale 2
entonces otra vez en este punto cuando x
es igual a 2 tenemos que tener una
pequeña discontinuidad y voy a dibujar
otro hueco en este punto cuando x vale 2
entonces vale 1 no lo estoy haciendo la
misma escala y entonces digamos que es y
aquí está el 4 aquí tengo el 2 y aquí ya
estaría el 1 aquí el 3
así que cuando x vale 2 y nuestra
función vale 1 es una función de un poco
caprichosa así la podemos definir y las
puedes definir como tú quieras y
observemos es la gráfica de x cuadrado a
lo largo de todos los valores excepto
cuando x vale 2 en donde hay un hueco o
sea no puede tomar el valor de x al
cuadrado porque x vale 2 y tenemos que
utilizar el valor de uno porque x vale 2
y utilizamos gdx gx que vale 1 cuando x
vale 2 exactamente en el punto cuando
vale 2 es en el único lugar donde vale 1
y en el resto se mantiene en la función
bueno debería decir en x que es igual a
x cuadrada bueno y es el momento de
hacer preguntas si fuera evaluar g de 2
bueno me remito a la definición entonces
cuando x vale 2 aquí me indica que tengo
que usar este valor que me dice que
tiene que ser igual a 1 pero
vamos a las preguntas interesantes por
ejemplo cuál es el límite cuando x se
aproxima a 2 dg x otra vez estamos
utilizando notación caprichosa pero
estamos preguntando algo realmente
simple que es lo que pasa cuando x se va
acercando cada vez más y más al 2 que le
pasa a gd x cuando x se acerca cada vez
más y más al número 2
a medida que x se va acercando a 2 y esa
es la definición rigurosa que hemos
venido utilizando cuál será el valor al
que se va acercando gdx es decir si
tengo 1.9 o 1.99 o 1.99 999 o veámoslo
por el otro lado qué valor toma de x
cuando x vale 2.1 o 2.09 o 2.01 y
observamos en la gráfica como x se va
acercando cada vez más al 2 y haciendo
un recorrido visual mientras x se acerca
a 2 podemos ver que la gráfica se va
acercando poco a poco
aun cuando el valor de la función cae a
1 el límite de la función cuando x se
acerca a 2 es igual a 4 también podemos
hacer esto de manera numérica y
hagámoslo con una calculadora a ver voy
a traer mi calculadora
tengo que encontrar la ni infalible
calculadora finalmente aquí está y
podríamos decir de manera numérica cuál
es el valor cuando x se acerca a dos
cuando x tiene el valor de 1.92 lo que
nos indican aquí así tenemos 1.9 al
cuadrado 3.61 pero qué pasa si me quiero
acercar más por ejemplo con un 1.99 así
que otra vez y esta vez obtengo 3.96 y
qué pasa si ahora utilizo 1.999 y a eso
lo elevó al cuadrado y ahora obtengo
3.996 y observen que si me quiero seguir
aproximando a nuestro punto
digamos que ahora utilizo 11.999 99 9999
al cuadrado que es lo que obtuve bueno
no será exactamente 4 porque la
calculadora hace redondeo pero podríamos
decir que en realidad estamos muy muy
muy muy muy cerca del 4 y podemos hacer
algo similar si nos acercamos del lado
derecho y obtendremos un resultado
similar al que obtuvimos cuando nos
acercamos por el otro lado veamos qué
pasa si ahora pruebo con 2.1 al cuadrado
obtengo 4.4 y ahora intentaré con 2.30
si 11 estamos más cercanos al 2 y lo
elevó al cuadrado y nos vamos acercando
cada vez más al 4 y entonces parece ser
que a medida que nos vamos acercando y
es una manera numérica de expresar lo
que el límite sin importar la dirección
en la que nos acerquemos de x cuando se
acerca a 2 aún cuando en ese punto esté
definido como 1 en el límite nos
acercamos al 4